- Let's close out with
one last musical story
I hope will bring you some joy.
This is what I'm liking.
(cheerful energetic music)
(audience clapping)
All hour we have seen just how
transformative music can be.
For the past 12 years, girls
in Nebraska have learned
that firsthand taking part in
a program that uses pop music
as a tool to instill self-assurance.
It's called Omaha Girls Rock,
and we have the executive director
on the line right now watching on KETV.
Everybody please say hello to Halley.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Hi.
- Hi.
- What's up?
So tell us more about the program.
- Oh my God, Kelly, I would love to.
So our mission at Omaha Girls
Rock is to empower youth
to use their voice, and
we do that through music.
So our organization has
year round programming.
We do instrument instruction,
we do afterschool programming,
but the biggest programming that we have,
and the most popular,
are our summer camps,
where in five days our youth,
with or without musical experience,
are learning an
instrument, forming a band,
writing an original song,
and, on the fifth day,
performing when they headline a showcase
at a local music venue.
So it is a phenomenal organization,
and it's my honor to be
able to be here with you.
- Oh my gosh, it sounds incredible.
I'd have loved to be a part
of this when I was a kid.
So you use popular music
to create conversations
with the kiddos.
So how do you do that?
- I think it's the easiest way
for our teaching artists
to begin relationships
or start forming those relationships
with the youth that we mentor.
So our youth come to us
with a variety of genres
that they're interested in
and that is where we begin our learning.
That is where we, you know,
instill the skills needed to
learn the guitar, for example.
But we also are using a
variety of those genres
and artists who are, you
know, local, national,
international, to talk
about how to take up space
and how to live in the
intersections of your identities
because there is not just
one way to be successful.
We use Lizzo, for example,
and we talk about, you know,
beginning with the flute, is
this a hip hop instrument?
And our youth, you know,
understand that those preconceived notions
about what a pop star is supposed to be,
what musicians rock, that is
up to each of us to decide.
So we are all about that self-empowerment
of learning the instrument
and also learning
to be powerful exactly as you
are, regardless of body size
regardless of race,
regardless of gender identity.
Releasing ourself from those standards
and truly just standing on
those stages in our truth.
- Man, it's incredible.
It's like you're helping
these kids find their power
and their purpose, like, all at once.
It's really, really cool.
Thank you so much for joining us,
and also I'm liking your post right now.
(post chiming)
(audience clapping)
- [Halley] Thank you.
- All right.
Well, that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you.
So they're gonna write a
check to Omaha Girls Rock
for a thousand dollars just to help out.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Amazing. Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much, Halley,
and thank you so much.
A big thank you to all our guests today:
Seal, Niall Horan, Shania Twain,
Ava Max, and Grace Gaustad.
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.